STEREN GIANNINI: Hi, I am
Steren Giannini, Senior Product
Manager at Google Cloud.
Welcome to "What's
New in Serverless?"
Today, we are mainly
going to talk about two
of our Serverless products,
Google Cloud Functions, which
is Serverless functions,
and Google Cloud
Run, which is Serverless
applications and containers.
First, I want to call
out that Serverless
is available in every
Google Cloud region.
You will find Clarin and
Cloud Functions in all
of the Google Cloud regions.
And you can expect us to open up
those products in future Google
Cloud regions.
All right.
Let us dive into
Cloud Functions.
So, first, we've been
hard at work delivering
a new runtimes for Cloud
Functions, new programming
languages.
The first one is Ruby.
then is .NET Core, PHP, and
we've also been updating
our existing runtimes with
Python 3.9 and Node.js 14,
and even 16 in preview.
Next, we added
more customization
to the build process.
So you might know that when you
deploy your function on Cloud
Function, the first
step that happens
is that this function is
built before it gets deployed.
So you can now
customize where that
build happens by targeting
a private worker pool.
This allows you to
customize the machine
types on which the
function will be built,
or to ensure that the function
is built within your VPC SC
perimeter.
We've also added the
ability to define
build environment variables.
So these en vars are en vars
available at build time.
They, for example, help
you configure the buildback
behavior.
And, finally, we delivered Min
instances to Cloud Functions.
So we've been hearing from you
that cold start is a problem
with function as a service.
So what is a cold start?
When your function
receives no traffic,
its number or function
instances are scaled to 0.
But then when traffic
arrives, Cloud Functions
will scale from 0
to 1, and the time
it takes for the
function to start
is what we call a cold start.
Thanks to Min instances, you
can simply define a value
that Cloud Functions
will scale down to,
keeping one or more
instances warm,
so that when the next
request comes in,
there are already some warm
instances to process them.
So when not in use,
those warm instances
are charged for memory, but
also for CPU at 10% the price.
To use Min instances, you can
do so via a simple command line
flag or user interface inputs.
Right now, I would
like to call out
two of the Google
Cloud orchestration
products that pair very well
with Cloud Functions and Cloud
Run.
The first one is
called Eventarc.
So Eventarc allows you to
asynchronously deliver events
from Google Services
software as a service,
and you own apps to
Serverless products.
Eventarc has added
a few new features--
the ability to target Cloud
Functions, the ability
to receive events
from Cloud Storage,
and a new standalone
user interface that
allow you to manage
your Eventarc
triggers in a central place.
Second, I want to
call out Workflows,
which is Google Cloud product
to orchestrate automate Google
Cloud and HTTP based API
services with a workflow
that you define.
So on the right, you can
see a screenshot of the user
interface where the workflow is
using a comprehensible syntax,
but can also be visualized
in a very nice graph.
So Workflows has added
a few new features.
First, the ability to use
HTTP callbacks, the ability
to connect to many
Google Cloud APIs.
It has increased the memory,
as well as the number
of concurrent executions.
And there were many syntax
and library enhancements.
All right.
Now let us dive into Cloud Run.
So, first, I want
to call out that we
have added committed use
discounts to Cloud Run.
So committed use
discounts allow you
to commit to an early spend
on Cloud Run for a year,
and you would-- you simply
receive a 17% discount
on this commitment.
Of course, usage above
the committed amount
is charged at normal rates.
This is self-service.
From the Cloud Console,
you go into Billing,
you click Commitment,
and this is
where you can purchase
the commitment for a year.
I should note that committed
use discounts apply
to all Cloud Run
services of your accounts
across all of your projects
for a given region.
Let's take an example.
On the right, we can see
an example Cloud Run bill
over time.
This, basically, reflects the
Cloud Run usage over time.
As you can see, because most of
the time, the bill is above $1,
it makes it very economical
in that situation
to commit to a $1 per
hour usage, because that
means that you would only
pay $0.83 for every hour.
And of course, if usage
goes above the commitment,
for example, because you
used $1.50 of Cloud Run,
then you would only pay
the discounted on the $1.00
and $0.50 above the dollar.
Now, I want to tell you how we
have been improving the Cloud
Run developer experience
with three things following
the development journey.
First, we have added local
development to Cloud Run.
Second, we are making it easier
to deploy your source code.
And third, we improved
the observability
of your Cloud Run services.
Let's take a look.
Local development-- this allows
you to run your Cloud Run
services in a local emulator.
This emulator is available
in the gcloud command line,
in the Cloud Code for VSCode,
in Cloud Code for IntelliJ
as well as in
Cloud Shell Editor,
the online IDE of Google Cloud.
If we take an
example, you can see
that you can store your Cloud
Run config in a file that
would allow you to define
how the emulator should
be configured.
Then, using a simple command,
gcloud beta code dev,
you start a local
development environment that
will emulate the
characteristics of Cloud Run,
with the CPU and
memory allocation
that you defined with
the environment variables
that you defined.
And it will watch your local
source code for changes,
and when they happen,
will rebuild them
into a container that-- and
restart the local server.
So quite handy for
a fast development
group instead of
deploying to the Cloud
for testing new changes.
Then, once you have
developed your service,
you want to deploy it.
We have added support
for deploying source code
to Cloud Run.
This is, basically, a command,
a very simple command,
in three words that will build,
push, and deploy your service
from local source code.
This command is
gcloud run deploy.
That's right.
That's the default
for gcloud run deploy.
It's to build your local
source code using Cloud Build,
push it to Artifact
Registry, and then deploy it
to Cloud Run.
This command is also leveraging
Google Cloud Buildpacks,
in order to allow you to
deploy source code in popular
languages without any
Dockerfile, that includes Go,
Node.js, Python, Java, and .Net.
But, of course, if a local
Dockerfile is present,
then this command
will simply build it
with the instructions that
are in the Dockerfile,
and deploy the arbitrary
container image to Cloud Run.
Lastly, we added more
observability to Cloud Run.
First, by delivering
a few more metrics,
notably, the instance
count metric,
which would show you
simply the number
of active and idle instances
for a given Cloud Run service.
Then, we've walked with
the Cloud AR Reporting team
to make sure AR reporting
was able to capture
system errors out of the box.
So without any
more configuration,
that means that, if your Cloud
Run container instance is out
of memory, or if
Cloud Run is not
able to scale because it is
reaching its max instance
limit, those errors that
are present in your logs
will now also be aggregated
in Cloud error reporting
and displayed in a very
actionable way in the Cloud Run
user interface.
And lastly, we have collaborated
with the Cloud Trace team
to provide out-of-the-box
request tracing.
That means that you can analyze
the latency of your Cloud Run
services using Cloud Trace
without any instrumentation
needed.
All right, now, I'm
going to tell you
how we have made it easier to
run more workloads on Cloud
Run with three changes.
First, giving you more control
around the CPU allocation
of your service.
Second, by delivering a
new execution environment.
And third, by pushing
the limits that
were historical
limits of Cloud Run.
Let's take a look.
CPU allocation--
let's take an example.
Here, you can see one container
instance of a Cloud Run
service.
It is starting.
Then it has started.
It receives requests,
potentially multiple requests
at the same time
thanks to concurrency.
And then at the end of its
life, it gets terminated.
Today, the CPU for
that container instance
would only be allocated when the
container instance is starting,
or when it is receiving
at least one request.
As a customer, you
would also only
be charged when the
CPU is allocated.
And, in particular, you are
charged for CPU and memory,
but also you are charged
every time a request arrives.
We are introducing the
ability to opt out of this CPU
throttling by simply saying
that you want the CPU to always
be allocated to your
controller instances
as long as the
instance is alive.
So in that case, you would
be charged, of course,
for the entire lifetime of
that continual instance.
But the CPU will always be
available to that container
instance.
You can enable this
via simple command line
flag on an existing
or a new service
as well as a simple checkbox
in the user interface.
So this new option to
always have CPU allocated
allows you to run background
tasks or async processing
after you have
returned requests.
It makes Cloud Run more
compatible with monitoring
agents like OpenTelemetry.
Many programming languages
do things asynchronously,
like Goroutines, or async,
or threads, or coroutines.
These are now more
compatible with Cloud Run.
And lastly, you can
deploy Spring Boot apps
that are expecting to
do background things.
And as I said, when you opt
in to this new CPU allocation
to always have
CPU allocated, you
are charged for a
different price.
There is no request fee.
And the CPU and
memory is 25% lower.
You can couple
this always on CPU
allocation with Min
instances, basically
allowing you to have
a number of instances
that are always scheduled,
and which always have CPU,
and looking at some quite
interesting use cases.
Next, you will find
that we've improved
the performances of
Cloud Run, as well
as we are adding network
file system support.
This is thanks to a new
execution environment
that we call Second Generation.
So, basically, when you deploy
a container image to Cloud Run,
it runs in the execution
environment, also known
as Sandbox.
So, today, you can opt into
the Second Generation execution
environment.
Again, using a simple command
line flag or user interface
button.
And this new sandbox
has increased network
in CPU performance, has
better Linux compatibility,
and allows you to use network
file system, like Cloud
Filestore, for example.
And, next, I should call
out that we are constantly
at work to increase the
limits of Cloud Run.
So, first, we have added
support for more protocols,
like Websockets, HTTP/2, and
gRPC bi-directional streaming.
All of these are
generally available now.
You can now pick up to 16
gigabytes of memory in preview,
up to 4 VCPUs.
Each request can run
for up to 16 minutes.
And each container
instance can process up
to 1,000 concurrent
requests at the same time.
This can become
very handy if you
are using Websockets and
opening many streams on a given
instance, for example.
Lastly, I want to tell
you how we have made Cloud
Run even easier to secure--
by meeting regulatory
frameworks,
by allowing you to put a secure
perimeter around your Cloud Run
services, and by helping you
secure your Cloud Run services.
So Cloud Run is now covered by
these regulatory frameworks.
We know this is very important
for enterprise settings.
I should call out FedRAMP
Moderate, PCI DSS, SOC 1, 2,
and 3.
All of these are now
covered for Cloud Run.
Next, how can you
secure or define
what is allowed to reach
your Cloud Run service?
Well, first, we have added
support for ingress control.
By default, all traffic
at a networking layer
is allowed to reach
your Cloud Run service.
But you can now restrict
the ingress to only allow
internal traffic, so that means
traffic coming from your VPC
or from Google Cloud,
like Cloud Webserve,
and you can allow internal
traffic plus traffic coming
from Google Cloud
Load Balancing.
Similarly, you can control where
the unknown request should go.
For example, when you
do an outbound request
to the internet, you can force
it to go through your VPC.
And by using ingress
and egress settings,
you can also enable
VPC service control,
allowing you to put your Cloud
Run services inside a VPC AC
perimeter.
Thanks to Cloud Run Integration
with Google Cloud Load
Balancing, you can
leverage Cloud Armor, which
is a web application firewall.
And you can use
identity aware proxy
to build internal
applications that
would only be accessible to
your employees, for example.
And, lastly, I want
to tell you how
we made it easier to secure
your Cloud Run services.
First, by providing a native
integration with Google Cloud
Secret Manager.
So Secret Manager is
a Google Cloud product
to store your secrets
in a secured place
with potentially your
own encryption keys.
You can now mount those
secrets as volumes or as
en vars inside your
Cloud Run services,
allowing you to
decouple your code,
your container from
its configuration,
or even its secret.
Then, we added more
security features.
Of course, you might know
that Cloud Run services run
with a certain
identity, so that means
you can provide a
service account that
would be used as the
identity of the code that
runs for a particular service.
And the service account can have
more or less IM permissions.
Notably, you can remove all
permission of a certain Cloud
Run service if this one is
not expected to call any APIs.
We are announcing the
general availability
of Binary Authorization
for Cloud Run.
Binary Authorization allows you
to define a policy regarding
which containers can or cannot
be deployed to Cloud Run.
And by using an
organizational policy,
you can enforce
Binary Authorization
to be applied to your Cloud Run
services in a set of projects.
Lastly, we delivered customer
manage encryption keys,
allowing you to bring
your own encryption
keys to encrypt the container
images deployed to Cloud Run.
And finally, we
haven't stopped here.
We are proactively
producing recommendations
to secure your
Cloud Run services.
The first one that
we delivered is
to recommend you to
use a dedicated service
account with a minimal set of
permissions for each production
Cloud Run services.
So to recap, we have added
many things to Cloud Run.
The first is committed
used discount,
allowing you to get a
discount of up to 17%
on the amount you commit.
We've improved, and we
are continuously improving
its developer experience,
with local development,
deploying from source
code, more metrics.
We've increased the
workloads that you
can deploy to Cloud
Run, with CPU allocation
controls, a Second Generation
execution environment,
or just by pushing the
limits of Cloud Run.
And, lastly, we made it easier
to secure your Cloud Run
services.
To learn more
about Serverless, I
recommend you those
three sessions--
Dev100, which is a
great introduction
to Serverless on GCP;
Dev201, which will deep
dive into some very cool
features of Cloud Functions,
including some that
are coming; and Dev205,
which will teach you how to
build event-driven applications
with Eventarc and Cloud Run.
Thanks for joining me today.
This was "What's
New in Serverless?"
Enjoy the rest of Cloud Next.